[Applause]
how is Halloween in Scotland you all do
Halloween oh yeah yeah Halloween is uh
is a bit of a celebration we still
celebrate but it's called San it's the
Celtic tradition uh so it's like the
Turning of the seasons from like summer
autumn into winter um and we do
celebrate and I I guess as a kid we call
it geing uh you guys call it you know
dress up and you go around people's
houses you get candy and stuff but um
one of the things we have to do was like
a sort of as a child I don't know why
now feels like torture but they put like
a barrel apples in water or or in a bowl
and you'd have to duck for apples
bobbing for apples is call for apples
ducking for apples and you have to like
bite it with your with your M but then
you get covered in water and then you
have to duck or Bob in flour for candy
so your face is getting covered in flour
and you got candy in your mouth and then
they have this um like sticky bun
covered in Trio it's on a string and
it's waving backwards and forwards and
you have to take a bite out of it so
you're getting covered in trial I don't
know why we do this to kids seems kind
of mean kind of mean actually my kids
would love
it what did you say it was covered in
tree coatal sorry what would you guys
call like honey like um it's now sugar
syrup like yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home